welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition in this video
we're breaking down the five bloods on
netflix
the spike lee film feels like it's come
at just the right time
and it features several comments on
society throughout this video we'll be
discussing those
its ending the cool little post credits
scene and
our general thoughts on the movie there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't seen the film yet then i highly
recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
and please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy
the video
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
the five bloods
okay so the five bloods follows four
vietnam vets
returning to the country to search for
the remains of their squad leader
and gold that they left there during the
war it's a pretty simple concept
but due to the events that happened to
the characters things become
a lot more complicated throughout this
video i'm probably gonna be saying
things that may either make you agree
with me
or disagree so to keep things balanced
i'll remove my personal opinion from
things
and just discuss how they're portrayed
in the film i will say each side has
elements that they get right
each side has elements that they get
wrong and i'd of course love to open up
a discussion in the comments on
whether you agree with the way that
things are put across in the movie or
not
or you can just dislike the video it's
entirely up to you anyway we follow paul
david otis eddie and melvin these
characters are named after the group the
temptations
and throughout they all deal with their
own temptations
which is a terrible pun one of my worst
but i think that their names were
purposely chosen
because it shows the bond between the
group and the brotherhood that they
develop whilst touring
the storyline is very straightforward
and it follows the four
in pulse and david as they go to vietnam
looking for the gold and the remains of
norman
after inadvertently entering a minefield
eddie is killed
and david steps on a mine but is saved
by the rest of the group
and three white activists that just so
happen to be passing
paul orders them to be tied up and after
having a change of heart
the rest of the group free them which
angers the character mercenaries arrive
to take the gold from them
and it's revealed that they've been
hired by a duplicitous character named
roche that originally agreed to help
them transport the treasure
paul goes into the jungle alone is
bitten by a snake
and he confronts his past he's killed by
the rosh's men
before they descend onto the rest of the
group killing the majority of them
except for david
otis hidy and simon at the end the gold
is donated to black lives matter
the group hidey was a part of and otis
decides to have a life with the daughter
that he never got a chance to
that's the basic plot and there are a
lot more nuances going on but
i just thought i'd give a general
overview before i discuss about the
commentary and the meaning behind
everything in the movie now one of the
main things you might notice straight
away
is that the film has four aspect ratios
that all represent different moods
concepts and ideas the past is shot in a
box format which was common during the
70s for news reports
and this gives the flashback scenes a
feeling of authenticity
it also adds a sort of idealized version
of the past which many of the characters
struggle with
in the present whilst in the city the
movie is shot in letterbox format which
gives the feeling of it being a film
this method of filming is used primarily
across movies and netflix shows
and to me it represents how vietnam has
become an almost americanized version of
the country
even though they won the war
corporations have taken over the major
cities
and thus the film is shot with a typical
american style
the film switches to a super right
format when the group are documenting
their journey
and lastly it goes full screen when they
enter the jungle
this is to show how expansive the
landscape is and how it almost envelopes
them in every way
tamiya also showcases that they have
entered the real world
and are either a stylized version of the
past or an almost corporate version of
the cities
these subtle differences really add to
the movie in several ways
and it helps us to distinguish between
what's really going on in the locations
i also love that they use rambo-esque
music in the past
and it really helps to bring the
historical elements to life
they also ride into vietnam on a boat
whilst flight of the valkyries play
which was often used on helicopter
speakers to intimidate the viet cong
it's clear that lee did his research
as the movie is thriving with historical
clips and speeches that add evidence to
what the director is trying to say
from the off we hear of squad leader
norman who is labeled as the greatest
soldier of all time
he represents an idealized version of
the past that shows the contradictions
laced throughout how we view history
if he really was the greatest soldier of
all time then one could argue that he
wouldn't have been killed
and though we learned that this was
actually at the hands of paul there are
clearly faults to his legend
to me this comments on how we often
idealize the past and tend to view it
with rose tinted glasses
paul wears a hat that says make america
great again but it could be argued that
if the country was so great it wouldn't
have led to the way that things
currently are where there are heavy
divisions
this is something that i've seen the
director and cass comment upon and it's
clear from the way that lee talks about
things that he definitely doesn't agree
with trump
so i think this message is coming across
strongly here but again i could be wrong
and this is just how i'm interpreting
the film from what i've seen people say
it's also worth noting that this hat is
passed from porter de roche
showing the symbolic passing of the hard
work of the african-american
then being taken by a white figurehead
and labeled as theirs
the fact that paul was the one that
killed norman and not the viet cong
also shows that it is human nature to
often bring an end to the ones that are
closest to us
and this is done through fear and
reacting without thinking
this is something that we see paul
demonstrate in the film and he hides
from the past and refuses to accept his
deeds until the end
which could also symbolize how we brush
over the more darker side of our history
in order to not accept some of the
atrocities we've committed
paul himself is seen as a contradiction
that claims to want the best for him and
those around him
but he lashes out betrays those that
help to save his son's life
and even calls his own child a
backstabber this is a haunting line that
are his last words to david
though he does get some closure in the
form of a letter it is quite sad that
this is the last thing that his father
actually says to him
now coupled with this david represents
the american soldiers that fought in
vietnam
here is a young man that was promised
something greater by his elders
but ultimately this turned out to be
untrue the relationship that the pair
have is a harsh one
and clearly paul holds a grudge against
david for something he couldn't control
which was the death of his mother and
paul's wife paul's a flawed man that
clearly has very different views from
his son and where he is a right-wing
trump supporter
david views the president as a clansman
in the oval office
there are also comments on how history
has been whitewashed in several ways
such as george washington being a slave
owner even though he's seen as one of
the greatest presidents of all time
and paul very much demonstrates the idea
of how lee views the vietnam war this is
late throughout the opening
in which we see muhammad ali saying that
he refused the draft because he didn't
want to go and kill
other people in the mud for a country
that hates him because of refusing to go
to war
ali was banned from boxing for three
years and though this was overturned
if he had ended up going to vietnam he
would have fought in a war that many
were protesting against
and one that we look back on is unjust
now mirroring this speech
with muhammad ali the film ends with one
by martin luther king
a man that wanted peace who was
ultimately assassinated because people
disagreed with him
norman is very much a martin luther king
like figure that wants peace more than
anything
and he too dies because of it norman
wanted unity
whereas paul is willing to blindly turn
against those that he should have a bond
with
because someone in power tells him to he
says he suffers from ptsd through ghosts
that visit him
was labelled a baby killer and spat on
by those that didn't serve
and it may have changed how he viewed
nationality and
in doing so made him turn to a political
figure that claimed to be able to turn
the nation back to what it was before he
was hated for his role in the war
this idea of trying to dig up the past
in order to get something back
is echoed in their other quest to find
norman's remains
ultimately trying to go back to this
does very little in the grand scheme of
things
and they realize that they're still
where they were at i love the line in
which paul tells derose that if it
wasn't for americans in world war ii
that he would be speaking german and
this carries a lot with it
it shows that he's ignorant to the
actual history and how all nations came
together to stop the country during the
war
and that this version of history in
which america saved everyone
simply isn't the truth this is similar
to how african-american contributions
are often overlooked
in favor of a white-washed version of
history in which they didn't play that
big of a part
even though the facts tell us otherwise
paul initially doesn't even want to see
norman
and he tells him to go away suggesting
that like many he's unable to deal with
the true realities of the past
african-american soldiers far outweighed
any of the demographics in the conflict
yet rambo is often showed as the face of
the war
similar eddie is thought of as a rich
man that has his face all over companies
but we learn he doesn't really own
anything and is broke
so he's labeled as having achieved
something when really he didn't
and it's others that did the work when
they learned that martin luther king has
been assassinated
paul wants blood but norman says that
they must have peace
when they discover the gold others want
it for the community but paul wants it
for himself
this short-sighted selfish view
ultimately leads to him being
alone and dying filled with regret over
the things he did
and the way that he treated his son the
others however die
as part of something or go on to reach a
more hopeful outcome
the movie opening with ally and ending
with king does indeed show us these
divisions
ali was a fighter that ultimately
refused to fight against those he viewed
as similar to himself
and norman was a peaceful man that
wished to one day see a version of
america that was truly equal
in the film both figures were killed but
they died with the hope
that things would change it's said that
money is the root of all evil
and this is exemplified in paul who
leaves his newly shot son in order to go
into the jungle with his share of the
gold
his greed is ultimately what does him
this is how the movie challenges us
and now paul is initially thought of as
a bad person in the end he does stick by
the other bloods
refusing to sell them out this shows
that he accepts that they are fighting
for the same fight
and after speaking to norman and seeing
the reality of this situation
he realizes that it's wrong to go
against those he has something in common
with
in order to serve powers above that
don't really care if he lives or dies
derose throws to make america great
again kappa otis at the end
showing that he didn't really care for
its ideals and was just perhaps using it
as a way to profit
however he's killed and otis gets to
live leading to the movie getting a
somewhat happy ending
otis builds a relationship with his
daughter a woman he knew nothing about
but finally embraced in order to move
forward this could exemplify how we must
embrace all facets of our history
even the ones that we are initially
ignorant to in order to move forward
into a new direction
money is given to melvin's family from
the gold and also donate it to black
lives matter
and heidi's foundation for landmines
this shows to me that they're trying to
donate to the future
in order to get things better whilst
also accepting culpability for the past
and the weapons that we use to harm
people during the war heedi feels
complicit for france colonising vietnam
and she's now paying back through
helping the country norman's remains
return
and we end on a message of hope with
david teaching black history at school
martin luther king takes us out saying
that there's hope for the future
but we must accept the past wrongdoings
and try to come to an
understanding with one another otherwise
both sides will suffer
never has this message been more
important now and in the air that has
truly beaten humanity from all angles
it's a very important thing to embrace
we must look to things that unify us
and not divide us and that is the true
message of the film
the movie ends with the entire crew
together in a post-credits scene saying
[ __ ] i know this is very short and sweet
it reminds us well we have we have been
through some sheet
but we can get through it together it's
also a call back to the wire which i
appreciate
now before we get into my final thoughts
i just want to let you know we're giving
away a free copy of the marvel phase
three part two box set to one random
subscriber
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the film in the comments
section below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 15th of june and the set
will be shipped out from then to over
against the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part so what did i think of the film
itself
well i'm sure you can guess i absolutely
love the movie
and i think it's one of spike lee's best
i haven't seen his entire
body of work but this definitely stands
at the top and it provides a lot of
social commentary
without being too heavy-handed in the
wake of the black lives matter protests
this film is needed now more than ever
and it comes at just an incredible
time i definitely think that this
provides a hopeful message
and it's something that we shouldn't shy
away from overall i really enjoyed the
film
and it gets a 9 out of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the movie and what you took
from it
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the entire mcu timeline which is going
to be linked at the end
we go through the chronology of the
infinity saga scene by scene
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early
if you want to come chat yourself to the
show either follow us at heavy spoilers
or click the discord link in the
description
below those are the best ways to keep up
to date with the channel and thanks for
sticking with me till the end
hope you have a great weekend take care
[Music]
[Music]
you